The other extreme, of course, is to use a direct
trie where instead of 1 bit per look up we might
have 1 memory access responsible for looking up a much
larger number of bits. So, for example, we might have a
2 level trie. Where the first memory access is dictated
by the first 24 bits of the address, and the second
memory access is dictated by last 8 bits of the address.
Now here, we can look up an entry in the forwarding
table with just two memory accesses, the
problem is that this structure results In a
very inefficient use of memory, unlike the single
bit trie. To see why suppose that we
want to represent a /16 prefix. Well unfortunately we have no way of encoding a
lookup that's just 16 bits. We have to
rather encode 2 to the 8th identical entries,
corresponding to the 2 to the 8th/24 prefixes that are
contained in that /16, so this is extremely inefficient use of memory.